[Music]
uh
[Music]
you're late i
found a companion along the way someone
from the studio
do you remember what you wrote me in
your last letter
well he is everything you spoke of
v meet zuleka
v pleasure um
you are a friend of joshua's
recent acquaintance more like
mama isn't back yet we can talk inside
until she returns
come in hurry up i'll be waiting outside
[Music]
good evening
our guest with us tonight is martin
coleman
an ordinary night citizen who well
martin how would you describe
your situation well as you can see i uh
i lost my arms please sit down
can i offer you anything a drink
i'm good thanks
in the name of the father and of the son
and of the holy spirit
one god amen
sulekha is the sister of the man i
killed
she wrote me letters while i was doing
time
that is how we too were united through
forgiveness
why we here and who are we waiting for
tell me v
do you believe in god
sure i believe zuleika and i
have a a running dispute i was thinking
you could help us resolve it
no no i never agreed to anything like
this
religious debates not my thing
there's nothing to debate those bd
studio hyenas
convince joshua to trade one execution
for another
his own crucifixion he wants everyone to
experience
his agony feel his pain and suffering
hang on a bd studio changed how
convict's gonna be executed doesn't the
law say something about that
corpse write the laws corpse choose the
judges
all it takes is a sit down between the
studio's ceo and the state's attorney
officially i'm here on a supervised
one-day furlough
but no law can prevent me from spending
that with new acquaintances
corruption's a sin too isn't it and
corruption got you here
this is much bigger than the laws of man
with this brain dance i'll take god's
message to billions
zulaika transformed me into a child of
god
it's time i repaid that debt i want to
bear witness to love's existence
in a manner that all the lost souls on
this wretched earth can understand
why love if unconditional love exists
then so must
god it's time the world was reminded of
his divine presence think
of the millions jacked into their feeds
like livestock
the children growing up in gang infested
streets
do they know love think of the joy toys
on jig jig street
coked out corpos in their offices and
murderers who stalk the streets
i want to reach them i will reach them
and think of paid killers like you
v have you known love
do you know what it is
we meet again and who are you
my name is v go
you are not welcome here mrs l amar
i have come to beg you for forgiveness
you
you murdered my son
that is something i can never forgive
i truly do regret the pain i have caused
you out of my house
no just go
please all of you
we should leave really please mrs
ellamar
it's okay just go you took my robin
from me my child
my son
let's go back to the car
just wish i could have talked to gloria
and i explained everything
and somehow i thought
i thought she'd find it in her heart to
forgive me
time to grab a bite to eat
who can blame her it's not easy to
forgive your son's murderer
stevenson we all knew how that would end
if you forgive anyone their sins they
are forgiven if you do not forgive them
they are not forgiven
you really want to do this get nailed to
a cross
yes it is something i
must do for if this won't shake the
world to its core
and wake us from our collective
nightmare then nothing will
[Music]
take stevenson inside grab a solid table
need a word with our stowaway here
i know i i heard no no
no wait up a sec i want to talk
so what do you think about our next big
bd star
he's got some organic chips loose need
psychiatric help
no no no my thoughts exactly
but it's too late for that if he's as
crazy as you say
why is he so important to you because
stevenson's got a little something
that's in short supply
but in very high demand
that little something's called
authenticity
in that brain composed entirely of cat
[ __ ] at this point
he truly believes what he says
huh sounds like the perfect bd actor
and one incapable of [ __ ] up in any
way
stevenson could be a fat old [ __ ]
gold vein for our studio
and that's my concern because
you're [ __ ] with his mind asking
probing questions you're making him
doubt
and most importantly jeopardizing my
investment
so i'm prepared to pay you double what
he's promised you to quietly walk
away yeah don't do it phoebe
all right then my answer's no can't
agree to that
why do i think you don't understand what
i'm offering you
understand just fine let's go inside
not bad for a petty merc off the streets
corporal rats think they can solve
everything with eddies
and you proved her wrong just don't make
her desperate
she's liable to bite back
what's your problem
seen every kind of dirtbag in this city
this jesus [ __ ]
ain't full of me you even think about
making a break for it
your ass is going down nobody's paying
you to open your mouth vasquez
got a tough customer with that vast case
even for a badge
he is set in his ways
like so many men
[Music]
can we please talk about something
besides faith
josh you're a knight godly choice
i don't know i spent years not
talking to anyone okay nothing hard
what do you do to relax
let's see i i read scripture
i watch brain dances and movies did you
hear about the remake of badlands raid
yeah kicks the original's ass trust me
chatter's pointless that's enough
stevenson can't be distracted he has to
focus now
relax rachel yes why
i don't know anything about you how do
you spend your leisure time
what do you do to online none of your
[ __ ] business
i mean it as a serious question i
meditate
great to have an outlet something to
give you peace of mind
true peace of mind can only come through
the spirit of divine grace
know what your problem is all of you i'm
talking to you you refuse to understand
that spirituality can only ever be
personal
and why the [ __ ] are you here anyway for
the free meal
outside your bedroom what if
you could leave all that back off my
mind okay
and maybe you should [ __ ] off you're not
part of our group
i
[Music]
guy just might be the biggest nut job
i've ever seen
but it's still corporate exploitation
feeling tired
bored powerless not anymore
experience all of chrome antichoice i
just feel better
we could talk in circles but who cares
what we think
what would it change corpse will
continue to grow rich off his type and
the masses will live on with their pipe
dreams
hang on where's rebel johnny you seem to
have lost him
well i found him he's inside that guy
he's the real rebel make up your mind
which is
nut job site he's [ __ ] in the head
the world's [ __ ] in the head and
you're [ __ ] in the head cause my
[ __ ] up head is inside it guess if you
want to save the world
that's the first step get [ __ ] in the
head
what do you think god exists
[ __ ] kill me please come on
serious question what
why so you flatlined then got your beat
back
don't tell me that's left you wondering
if a construct can even be
saved last year the city council of
night city weird as [ __ ] today
unreal but reality beckons
[Music]
the catastrophic city of